what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it's been a while but Marvel is back
with their latest show secret Invasion
so right away let me know your thoughts
on secret Invasion so far what did you
think about episode one and also let us
know who you think is a scroll I know I
have my eye on a few people who I
believe could be scroll but let me know
what you think in the comments right
away and also just to get this out of
the way this is a full breakdown of
secret Invasion episode one so needless
to say there will be spoilers talked
about in this video if you are trying to
avoid any and all spoilers this is your
warning and speaking of spoilers we're
going to dive right into this with the
ending the supposed death and I say that
very purposefully of Maria Hill she has
been in the MCU for a very long time and
she was a pretty big part of the first
Avengers film and she's been a pretty
big part of the MCU since then and the
end of of episode 1 showed us her dying
graphic transformed himself into Nick
Fury he went up to Maria Hill she
thought it was Fury but it wasn't it was
gravic and he shot her and at the end he
supposedly killed her now the big
question is is she actually dead do you
think so let us know in the comments
right now I personally do not think she
is dead I think there are too many
variables in this show and simply in the
MCU that could make it to where she is
still alive one is that this character
could be a scroll we have literally seen
a scroll disguised as Maria Hill in fact
palos's wife was disguised as her and
Spider-Man far from home so could this
simply be another scroll disguised as
Maria Hill or is she really dead now
I'll play Deadpool's Advocate to my own
Theory here we did kind of see her die
and she did not turn into a scroll which
they do as we saw in episode one but
maybe they cut away just a little bit
too early for us to actually see that
and another thing is obviously in
certain situations for spec special
people they do get brought back in some
way shape or form we think about Agent
Coulson from the very first Avengers
film Loki stabbed him through the back
out his chest they still managed to
revive him so that is also a possibility
as well but at the same time I will say
if you want to start a show with a bang
and truly show us that the Scrolls and
specifically their leader graphic means
business killing off a beloved character
who we've had in the MCU for a very long
time is a great way to show that and
after this you can't really complain
about Stakes when they killed off a
major important character but will she
return in a future episode we will have
to wait and see now throughout this
episode there are very important things
that you need to make sure that you know
moving forward in episode 2 and Beyond
so let's go ahead and break this thing
down scene by scene now we open up in
Moscow with who we think is Everett Ross
played by Martin Freeman of course we go
on to find out it is not he gets a call
from agent Prescott and he says he'll be
right there Then agent Prescott
into a monologue narration he is
speaking to Everett Ross but he's also
speaking to us the audience and with
this monologue they are basically
putting the notion in our head that we
can't trust anyone and what they do is
try to relate it to our actual lives our
real lives that way the show is that
much more compelling and they do a great
job at that he starts off by saying
imagine a world where information can't
be trusted it's not very hard is it
which it's not not with all of the apps
that we have nowadays not with targeted
advertising plus not to mention your
phones are pretty much always listening
to you but he continues and goes Society
starts to fray if you can't trust
information he says all we can turn to
are the people we care about but what if
those people aren't who we thought they
were what if the ones closest to us the
ones we trusted our whole lives were
someone else entirely and that right
there is basically the premise of the
entire show the story is about aliens
who can shape-shift who are now fighting
against Earth essentially and humans and
specifically the ones fighting against
the scroll have no idea who they can
trust ever because they think they can
trust somebody but they could be a
scroll in Disguise and agent Prescott
has caught on to what the scroll
Rebellion is doing he has gone full
Charlie Day meme in this scene we see
him connecting a lot of different events
with yarn we see his Post-it notes that
say but got a terror connected to Heist
who is the target we see more Post-its
that say Terror in Munich mass shooting
motive question mark we see other
newspaper articles that say London
explosion a Post-It that says 26 dead he
is basically tracking separate events
and in this scene he explains that they
are all linked because they are all
scroll disguised as other humans
pretending they are from a certain
Nation attacking another Nation so that
the world will essentially be at War and
agent Prescott explains this with a
major desperation yes he is coming off
as a crazy conspiracist but in this this
case he is right and he knows that he is
right and he seems a little desperate
and he seems a little hopeless as well
he connects everything he says there
have been five attacks in this year
alone each claimed by a different group
but that's what they want you to think
he says Argentina taxes Colombia and
then Colombia taxed the Philippines and
these acts are basically starting a
World War which of course is what the
scroll want the scroll are disguised as
other countries and they're basically
going around pissing off the other
countries of the world blaming it on
whoever they are basically causing a
chain reaction and now the world is at
War and two of courses behind it the
scroll now Ross laughs at it now of
course we know he laughs at it because
he is indeed a scroll and he doesn't
want him to know everything but then
Prescott takes us down memory Road and
says come on this didn't start yesterday
it started 30 years ago and he's talking
about the events that took place in
Captain Marvel and he says Carol Danvers
AKA Captain Marvel and Nick Fury promise
to find the scroll a home now it's 30
years later Fury did not deliver on his
promise they do not have a home but now
they want Earth and Prescott tries to
set the setting for the show even more
by saying there could be thousands or
tens of thousands out there we don't
know now fake Ross says that but their
only contact is Fury there are allies
but Prescott points to the fact that
Fury has been gone four years now on
saber now saber is the space station
that we saw in the post-credits scene of
Spider-Man no way home when Talos called
Nick Fury he was on saber that's where
we saw him with other scroll we also see
him on saber in the trailer for the
Marvels Captain Marvel 2. so no doubt
that this show will tie into the Marvels
now fake Ross says that I can't just
call Nick Fury I need actual evidence
and that's what Prescott has now
Prescott gives him this evidence and he
says I can only show it to you because I
don't know who to trust but right when
he says that he gets this really odd
look on his face and what he's thinking
in this moment is wait how do I know
this is Ross I don't know know this
could be a scroll now what he gave him
was essentially an attack plan of the
scroll their next attack that we see
happen at the end of this episode we
don't get a full glimpse of the Hologram
but what we can make out at the very
bottom is we do see gravic in his scroll
form and as it continues he turns into
his human form we haven't seen him in
his scroll form yet not in episode one
they're probably saving that reveal for
later now as he says I don't know who I
can trust anymore Ross says hey look you
can trust me I'll take this to Fury but
Prescott knows what's up he knows he's a
scroll and he attacks him and he almost
kills him but unfortunately this scroll
does end up shooting and killing
Prescott and I find this whole beginning
scene quite interesting because they are
trying to play this off like some people
that we have seen in real life and have
essentially been made fun of and had
movies and shows made about them that
big conspiracy theorist person who
believes aliens are out there who
believes aliens have infiltrated us that
of course nobody believes but in this
instance he turns out to be right the a
crazy conspiracy guy is right the aliens
have infiltrated us now of course at
this point in time we don't know that
Ross is a scroll so we think that a
scroll is chasing him he runs he runs he
runs and what's really interesting here
is that he actually calls for an
extraction and Maria Hill is there to
intercept so she truly believes that
this is Everett Ross he has Everett
Ross's phone he has Tech that he can
communicate with Maria Hill with and we
know from Black Panther wakanda forever
Ross isn't here right now he's actually
probably in wakanda but this shows us
that the scroll have infiltrated swords
so we wonder what else have they
infiltrated now the scroll disguise as
Ross runs until he makes a jump that he
can't actually make he falls he gets
really really hurt the person chasing
him reveals himself to be Talos and
here's a real important line the scroll
ends up dying and Maria says he's one of
you but Halo says no he's one of them
and what he me means is no he's not one
of me I'm a scroll that is on your side
but now there is a scroll resistance
rebelling against us who are tired
waiting on that promise of a new world a
new home for them and they are now going
to take Earth as their new home so we
have a division with the scroll where
they were all good before they were all
trusting of Nick Fury but because he has
not kept his promise and Carol Danvers
as well they don't care anymore they're
pissed and they're taking what is theirs
so we cut past the opening credits and
we go to Nick Fury arriving on Earth
from saber and if you notice this is not
the same Nick Fury that we know he
touches the ground because he hasn't
felt the actual Earth in a very long
time then he touches his knee because
now he's on Earth with far more gravity
than the artificial gravity that they
had on saber Maria Hill shows up to pick
him up and he limps over to her showing
us that this really isn't the Nick Fury
we know and that is a pretty common
theme throughout this entire first
episode Fury finally meets up with Talos
and he sees that he has grown a scroll
plant on Earth he says that his wife
Soren brought them wherever she went so
she must have brought some seeds or
actual flowers from their Homeworld when
they came to Earth he's planted it and
it is grown proving that their plants
their habitat can survive on Earth Fury
says you've always believed that could
happen and Tayla says I still do and
that's important because that shows that
Talos is still on Fury's side and still
believes that the scroll the good ones
and in his heart the rebels can still
peacefully coincide with humans he even
says it's changed since she planted it
it's adapted and that is kind of what
the scroll have done they have changed
they've adapted since they've been on
Earth they greet each other by touching
their heads together and this has been
explained to be a scroll greeting it is
very intimate and it shows us that Nick
Fury and Talos care for each other a
great deal now Fury says that he is so
sorry and what he is referring to here
is the death of Taylor's his wife Soren
we find out that she died later on in
the episode where Talos tells his
daughter Gaia but Taylor says she
worried that it would take something
like this to bring you back down to
earth Halo says I guess she was right
and Nick Fury you can tell really takes
that to heart he is really affected by
it especially because he knows that this
is kind of his fault he did not find the
scroll another world to live on he
didn't find them a home and here we find
out why Nick Fury is different Taylor
says we did what we can to help you
stick true to your promise but after the
blip after Nick Fury was snapped and
then came back he was different and then
he disappeared he left Earth and went to
saber then Carol Danvers also
disappeared then he says that his
daughter Gaia disappeared he was played
by Emilio Clark that we meet later on in
the episode then he says something very
important he explains that he was kicked
off of the council now he's talking
about a scroll Council the leaders of
the scroll who determine kind of what
they do he was kicked off and now gravik
the main villain of the show is put on
the council and Talos was exiled so it
basically tells us Halos has no more
power with the scroll and most of them
are with graphic including his daughter
Gaia we learned from the plans that
agent Prescott got that the scroll are
living basically at nuclear plants
because they are not affected by
radiation and humans are so they'll
never go near them and if they do
they'll just kill them anyways but
here's where the scroll plan is revealed
there's a radicalist group called the
AARP Americans against Russia the skulls
plan are to shape-shift and disguise
themselves as the AARP and attack Russia
making it seem like the United States
are the ones who attacked Russia
starting a World War Halos explains if
this happens your species will cease to
exist because gravic is basically going
to unleash war and weapons and nuclear
weapons and War are essentially going to
wipe out the humans until their only
scroll remaining so this establishes the
threat of the scroll it's not just that
they are disguising themselves as prob
probably high up officials in different
countries but they are also trying to
kill basically all humans and take the
world as their own they're not trying to
rule over humans they want the humans
completely gone and they want Earth to
be the home of the scroll then we cut to
a clip of roadie who is working for the
president basically ratting out Fury and
Maria Hill he says Hey Fury left saber
and they intercepted an encrypted
message from Maria Hill to Nick Fury
that they can't decode and he tells the
president both of them went AWOL which
stands for absent without official leave
meaning they left when they weren't
supposed to now the President says Fury
was developing the most complex
Aerospace defense system in the history
of mankind he can't just leave and he
tells Roddy to deal with it now this
scene right here makes me think that
Roadie might be a scroll it's very odd
that he would just rat out Nick Fury and
Maria Hill like this especially given
all of their history together with the
Avengers however Roadie is a high
positioned official now perhaps he could
just be taking his job rather seriously
but go ahead and let let us know in the
comments down below do you think Roadie
is a scroll or not now we see that Fury
went for a walk and he did this for a
very intentional purpose he wanted to be
found by MI6 but quick important little
detail here as he's walking down the
street he sees two people making out
they stop and the woman looks at him
this is the woman that graphic would
turn into at the very end of the episode
right before he sets off the bombs this
shows us that graphic has been following
him everywhere he knows Fury's moves
because he is literally following Fury
in Disguise and of course Fury wouldn't
know although it does look like he has a
hunch right here we then see a little
girl throw a ball and we see the same
ball later on in that scene when graphic
is switching people as well again
confirming gravic has been following
Fury disguised as other people now again
Fury went on the walk so he could
intentionally get kidnapped by Sonia
fallsworth the head of MI6 and that is
exactly what happens he gets kidnapped
they start saying hello and fury Barry
spylike puts a contact lens camera on an
owl statue this of course is so he can
infiltrate later and listen in and see
what she is going to say about the
scroll and what their plans are to take
care of the scroll now what's
interesting here is that ballsworth
knows he was in saber she says is this
why you came down from your little space
station because she knows that Nick Fury
personally knows graphic telling us that
there is a pretty big history between
the two of them and we find this out
more in episode 2. now Fury asked Sonia
what she knows about recent scroll
activity she says nothing and he says
hey look I know you're lying obviously
but then Sonya drops the bomb she says I
think thanos's snap changed you which is
exactly what Taylor said and again this
is telling us this Nick Fury is not the
same Nick Fury that we've known from the
Avengers and because of this Sonia does
not want to work with Nick Fury MI6 does
not want to work with well Rogue sword
agents and especially fury because he
hasn't been in the game in a long time
now she even says hey you didn't see my
men coming so there's no way you'll see
the scroll coming however of course Nick
Fury did get captured on purpose so they
could take him to Sonia however at the
same time we know graphic is watching
him he's right next to him and fury
doesn't know that so he doesn't see the
scroll coming Sonia says yeah we've
worked together in the past but no we're
not working together now you should go
back home you are not the same person
but the whole entire reason that Nick
Fury wanted to get captured is not
because he thought she was going to tell
him everything that she knew in fact he
knew she wouldn't he just wanted to put
that camera and microphone in her room
so he could listen to what she won't
tell him then we cut to one of those
nuclear plants that they said the scroll
we're living at we see a young man walk
up to a gate the guards ask what do you
want and he says home in my own skin and
this is no doubt a code a phrase used by
the scroll to let the others know hey
I'm a scroll it's me but of course they
still have to test this as Gaia comes
out she says take your natural form
basically prove your scroll he does and
Gaia says welcome to New scrollos now
scrollos was the original Planet that
the scroll are from they are now on
Earth and they are trying to take it for
themselves so they call it new scrollers
now in the car on the way to their base
guy asked Beto when the last time he ate
was he says he doesn't know so it's
obviously been a very long time she
opens up the glove box and shows him
some type of a fruit from scrollos their
Homeworld and she says whatever you did
to get here it was worth it so whatever
dangerous you put yourself in it's worth
it because we basically have our home
here so this shows us that Gaia truly
does believe in this cause but she
specifically believes in helping her
fellow scroll and finding a new home she
doesn't necessarily believe in
eliminating the entire human race she
more believes in helping be a refuge for
people a safe haven and she even says
that no not all of these people here are
a part of the resistance they come here
to to seek shelter to be safe and to be
who they are and we see little scroll
children playing having fun we see
people cooking and making food and she
explains that there are 500 strong
however they can't leave that is why
they take their scroll forms because
they can't leave however the people in
the resistance the Warriors they can
leave but when they leave they have to
stay attached to their shell meaning
they can't take the true scroll form
that way it makes it a lot harder for
people to detect who they actually are
the next thing we find out what the
scroll are really up to we find out that
they really are a lot more dangerous
than we know we see a warrior pledging
himself to the cause and then they say
bring out the shell and the shell is a
human a human that was a part of the AAR
Americans against Russia so the scroll
takes the shape of this American then
they put him in some type of scroll
device that they have made that
seemingly kind of puts them in a
coma-like state which then allows the
scroll to take their minds so this is
extremely dangerous because because they
could not remember everything before
they could only remember a handful of
years but now with this technology it
looks like when they take the shape of
somebody and take their mind they can
remember everything about this person's
life every moment so they could
literally become this person and nobody
could really ever know and this is why
the scroll are such a huge threat Roadie
could be a scroll Maria Hill could have
been a scroll the president could be a
scroll Hawkeye Spider-Man literally
anybody can be a scroll now we've seen
this technology used in Captain Marvel
but it looks like they somehow managed
to make this technology work again on
Earth and this is what they have been
using to disguise themselves as other
countries attacking other countries in
this example they are disguising
themselves as Americans and they are
going to attack Russia to try and get a
war started between the United States
and Russia they are essentially having
these countries attack each other to do
the work for them the scroll don't have
to kill everybody if everybody is
already killing each other now we cut
back to Nick Fury Kalos and Maria Hill
and the camera that Nick Fury inserted
before at Sonia's place is paying off
big time he spies on them and
essentially learns that there are only a
few people in Russia who could make the
bombs that the scroll plan on using and
they pinpoint it down to one and Sonia
says they're going there they're gonna
infiltrate it they're gonna take him out
and fury says all right we're going and
yeah we're gonna take out MI6 operatives
because if they get to them first then
they are going to kill all of the scroll
not just the rebels not just the bad
ones but literally all of them and Talos
and fury know they're not all bad there
are a lot of good scroll out there but
if they don't get to them first Sonia
and MI6 are gonna kill everyone now here
we finally meet gravic our main villain
who has quickly told that Fury has
landed back on Earth he is here in
Russia but Pagan tells them there's
nothing to worry about they say he looks
old he walks with a limp but graphic
knows this he has been watching Fury he
has been keeping track of him and I
learned in my interview with Kingsley
benedir the actor who plays graphic that
one graphic does not trust anybody which
is why he keeps tabs on everything
himself and two he kind of messes and
toys with people not just Fury but his
own people as well because he doesn't
trust anybody so when Pagan tells him
you are the cause he says no I'm not the
cause kind of talking down to him like
you idiot I'm not the cause a new home
is the cause and now they're going out
to enact their plan they're not going to
stop until the Earth is theirs and then
we see Pagan grab Gaia we find out that
it's her job to go and get the bombs
from this dirty bomb maker that Sonia
was talking about so now we have three
different parties going after the bombs
we have the scroll we have Sonia with
MI6 and we have Nick Fury Maria Hill and
Talos all trying to get the bombs MI6 is
there first so Talos very easily takes
out the MI6 operatives he doesn't kill
them because that's not what Taylor's
wants to do but he does take them out so
MI6 is out of the game so now it is just
Taylor's fairy and Hill against Gaia
Fury tries to get in the back way but
there's a chain on the door in which
Talos easily breaks and this shows us
that the scroll are a bit stronger than
humans and some of them are a lot
stronger than humans because Talos
easily rips this chain off the door then
we get an awesome joke here when Talos
rips the chain off the door Nick Fury
says not bad for 136 year old but Talos
explains he's not even in his 40s yet in
human years he hasn't even gone through
his midlife crisis but then he asked
Fury what he got for his midlife crisis
and he says the Avengers which is a
pretty great joke that we love to hear
and it also tells us that the Avengers
are his team he started the Avengers
Initiative and as we've seen in some of
the trailers that have come out for
secret Invasion Fury says that he can't
call in The Avengers because this is his
fight he has to fight this alone plus
not to mention who knows if he could
even trust any of the Avengers that
would show up they could be scroll so
Nick Fury and Talos go inside but
they're a little late Gaia has already
gotten the bombs but Maria Hill spots
her as he's trying to leave she lets
duck Ferry now and says that she's gonna
tell her then we come to a very
interesting scene Nick Fury and Talos go
to talk to the person who they know to
be the dirty bomb maker he of course is
disguised as somebody who sells Fine Art
and highly valued Collectibles like the
king Louis chair that Nick Fury sits in
and here we see a few things one we see
some really good spy work we see Nick
Fury in action and we also know that
they have Intel on this person he says
he has a meeting with his wife but Fury
says to agent Keller a code name that he
is calling Taylor so he doesn't have to
actually say Taylor so the scroll
doesn't know who he is he asks if he has
a wife and he says no our Intel says
that he is divorced and she lives in
Miami so they know he's lying Fury says
everybody gets one line nobody gets two
of course he lies again saying he
doesn't know anything about a dirty bomb
doesn't even know the term but then
Talos steps in and finds out quickly
that he is a scroll and then he says
your name is not Keller it's Taylor so
this person this scroll Acts actually
recognizes the human form that Talos
takes now remember Talos was exiled and
he's a big enemy of gravic which means a
lot of people probably know who Talos is
and know his human form but the other
interesting part about this scene here
is that Talos does not want the help of
Nick Fury he says it is his fight even
when he is seemingly getting beaten he
says no it's my fight but ultimately
Fury ends up killing the scroll and
Talos is pretty upset after stating that
it was his fight and I believe that he
says this because he didn't want to
actually kill the scroll he doesn't want
to harm fellow scroll he understands
that some are frustrated but he doesn't
want to kill any of them so maybe he was
hoping to just detain him so he's pretty
upset when Fury kills him meanwhile
Maria Hill is following Gaia and they
get into a fight in which Gaia wins
pretty easily because she's a scroll
they're stronger than humans however
Talos follows and quickly realizes that
it's his daughter Gaia who ran away from
him and his wife her mother they talk
and he says the last thing your mother
taught told me was to find you
essentially telling Gaia your mother is
dead and Taylor says that the people
responsible for it are the people that
she is with ravik Taylor's tries to get
the bombs from his daughter he even puts
his gun down because he's not gonna harm
his daughter and he wants her to come
back to his side she says no and even
gives him the littlest tiniest push and
he kind of just accepts that and he lets
her go he can't stop her but he lets her
go in hopes that he can actually
persuade her to come back to his side
she gets away and hides and takes a
moment to mourn the loss of her mother
then furion he'll go to a bar and fury
is staring in the mirror then a random
man at the bar says you can stare all
you want but you'll never be the man you
once were now if you notice this man is
one of the people that gravic transforms
into in the final scene when Fury is
chasing him so it seems like this man
right here at the bar is graphic and he
is kind of like I mentioned toying with
Fury at this point in time stating
you'll never be the man that you once
were you are not the same Fury and this
is the exact conversation that Nick Fury
and Hill have while they're playing
chess and once again we hear that Fury
was never the same after the blip and
Hill got dusted too let's not forget
that but she says you haven't been the
same since that happened you have been a
different person and you are not ready
for this now Gaia delivers the bombs but
she does lie she says somebody was
waiting for me Pagan ass if it's someone
she can identify and she lies and says
no obviously she can it's her father but
since this group The Resistance
apparently killed her mom she no longer
trusts them and she suggests postponing
the attack but they say no they now have
the bait so then we see her meet up with
her father how they got in contact with
each other remains to be a mystery at
this point in time perhaps they have
cellular devices that the others don't
know about and perhaps can't detect any
signal or messages from but they do get
in contact with each other both
disguised obviously Talos is a cab
driver he picks her up when she's this
guy says another woman and Gaia
basically says the attack is tomorrow
and graphic knows you'll be there
Taylor's asks how and she says she
doesn't know but he knows that they're
gonna be there because he has been
disguised as these random people
following Nick Fury or and I have a
theory about this he might not trust
Gaia and he might actually rely on her
not trusting him to deliver the
information to them to make sure they
actually know this could be a setup a
roux by graphic because it seems like he
clearly doesn't trust her but trust that
she'll go and tell her father what is
about to happen and I think it's
probably a bit of both graphic is
definitely following Nick Fury around
disguise of these other people but he
definitely doesn't trust Gaia either and
for good measure Gaia is now back on the
side of her father and fury and tells
them the whole entire plan and says the
bags of the bombs will be marked with
infrared X's so of course in the next
scene Talos Fury and Hill have glasses
that can detect infrared spray they
follow the bags that Gaia has but then
they quickly lose the bags they split up
and they go chase them what ends up
happening is Taylor's chases one bag
Hill chases another and then Fury runs
into the same girl with the same ball on
the street and obviously this catches
him by surprise because he wasn't
expecting to see her there and the ball
that she is holding is very
distinguishable it sticks out so he
instantly realizes what is happening so
Fury ends up following her and the first
time that she goes out of sight she
turns into the man from the bar he goes
out of sight again and turns into the
woman who was making out with the guy on
the side of the street that Fury came
across then once again out of sight and
turns into gravic in human form and this
is where they realize it's all a trap
the bags are decoys the bomb's already
in place graphic turns around holds up
the Detonator wastes no time at all
which I love looks at Fury gives him a
little smirk detonates the bomb killing
thousands of people graphic walks away
just staring Fury down until of course
gravic disguises himself as Nick Fury
goes up to Hill shoots her and kills her
so we think and this shows us that
gravic has no mercy at all he blew blew
up an entire town square and he killed
Maria Hill and if you notice as he's
over Maria and he sees Nick Fury come up
he looks up and he is smiling because he
is torturing Fury he just killed one of
the persons that he cares about the most
in the world so he looks at him with a
big smile on his face but another bomb
goes off he turns back into his human
form and then he leaves and then Hill
dies and Nick beer and Talos get out of
there and that is episode one a great
ending to the first episode definitely a
cliffhanger however a fantastic episode
but let us know your thoughts about it
in the comments down below what did you
think of it did you like it please let
us know did you spot any cool Easter
eggs that we may have missed don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
and leave a comment so you can enter our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month also we have a patreon
account if you want to further support
the channel we have a Discord server
that you can join and we have a website
as well we'll link all of those down
below and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof
foreign